now to last night's American Music
Awards so many memorable moments but
let's start with one of the most talked
about Chris Brown food as Kelly Rowland
comes to his defense our Denny directo
was there
I love the fact that at the amas it's
very spontaneous Chris Brown
you never know what to expect
Now Chris Brown is not here tonight so
I'm accepting this award on his behalf
excuse me chill out
well winner Chris was actually set to
perform this 40th anniversary tribute to
Michael Jackson's Thriller album
he posted the rehearsal video two days
before the awards later captioning it
you serious and quote they canceled me
for reasons unknown
a spokesperson for Dick Clark production
tells E.T we couldn't align on the
performance to no fault of Chris Brown
Twitter had other theories pointing to
Chris's 2009 assault on Rihanna one user
wrote the song was beat it the nerve on
so many levels
and a source confirms to E.T singer
Sierra was supposed to be part of the
tribute she posted this rehearsal video
with Chris calling him a rare breed of
this generation meanwhile Pink's two
performances made headlines we've seen
you in silks we've seen you rigged up
and now skates you really need to give
people a reason to pray you're like two
feet on the ground do you
yesterday
[Music]
who's better at roller skating you or
your mom probably
[Music]
from skating around in fishnets and hot
pants to Donny's sequins and feathers in
a gown Cher gifted her from her last
tour the singer also paid tribute to the
late Olivia Newton John
[Music]
she was an absolute icon I loved her
voice my daughter just got done doing
grease in her theater production and she
actually helped me learn the song
I know
this is the one huh this is the
centerpiece yes Lionel Richie was
overcome with love after Stevie Wonder
and Charlie puth's Dueling Piano tribute
for the recipient of the icon award
which means I lived to receive it and
when you see your fellow American Idol
judges do they have to refer to you as
icon now
don't get Luke and Katie
Lionel pose with fellow icon Smokey
Robinson who's totally fine when people
confuse him for his good friend many
times people have come to me and call me
Lionel hey Lionel can I have your
autograph so when they do that I sign
love on Lionel Richie
[Music]
Taylor Swift
hi E.T yeah the ama's most awarded
artists swept the show winning six out
of six congratulations Taylor
the biggest surprise of the night cardi
B hitting the stage with gorilla in her
first public appearance since takeoff's
Memorial nine days ago that girl really
has your back what's it like to have
cardi B support it's a thing that's my
cousin I love her
also showing up unannounced Missy
Elliott performing with favorite female
Latin artist winner Anika
congratulations
is going amazing Anita embraced the
Black and White theme of the night along
with new artists of the Year winner Dove
Cameron on the heels of the tragedy that
happened at Club Q in Colorado Springs I
want to remind everyone how important
queer visibility is I have to thank the
queer Community for embracing these so
wholeheartedly
suit is really uncomfortable to pee in
MGK made a rare appearance without Megan
Fox on his spiky arm but with his
world's best boss mug in hand MGK's suit
you were sitting right next to those
spikes but listen let me tell you
something the first thing I did was how
pointed are they he said noise salt and
I tested it out okay it's good meanwhile
Bebe rexell went up to her big blue MTV
EMA look from last week with this red
tool Ensemble got someone watching that
train for you tonight yes
I know I'm hoping somebody steps on it
I'm just kidding just kidding you chose
Comfort tonight right we're trying to
always choose Comfort
um
Dan and Shay Dan and Shay walked away
with their fourth consecutive win in the
same category but it's what soon to be
dad of three Shane Mooney loss that's
got him feeling good he lost like 50
pounds what inspired the change it
wasn't just to lose weight it was to be
more healthy and I think I'm down 53 now
so I feel great yes I turned up to dress
up host Wayne Brady brought 19 year old
daughter Miley to the party she's gonna
be hosting it one day he rocked four
different looks through the night and
brought out Dan's partner Whitney Carson
for his opening number how did you
settle on this for the red carpet
Dancing with the Stars I've lost 15 to
16 pounds come on my brother's belt is
all can be so why wouldn't I why why
wouldn't I show it off in fact you're
lucky that the search button because I
was having like an r b moment earlier
foreign